well let's speak to journalist Julia
chapavalova in Moscow and Julia the
Russian President Vladimir Putin has
been talking about the situation what
exactly has he been saying
yeah now we've heard from President
Putin regarding the disaster and he
disgusted with Turkish president erdogan
during a telephone conversation the
Russian president called the destruction
of the kahovska power plant a barbaric
action by Kiev adding that it was
instigated by the West Putin stated that
the breakdown of the power station was a
clear example of kiev's terrorist
methods so now we've heard from all the
Russian top officials regarding the
destruction of the kahovskar dam and all
of them plays the blame solely on Kiev
by the way prior to the telephone call
with Vladimir Putin Mr Edward had a
conversation with President zielinski of
Ukraine offering to create a commission
with the participation of the UN Russia
Ukraine and turkey to investigate what
actually happened
basically we understand that Ukraine
accuses Russian troops of blowing out
the dam Russia claims that the power
station came under Ukrainian shelling
but there is also a version that it
could be an unintentional disaster and
the dam collapsed due to improper
maintenance and the Damage due to the
damage caused earlier so obviously
experts now say that the destruction of
the dam May negatively affect both sides
of the conflict and just a little bit
more on the damage what's the risk of
further flooding on the
russian-controlled side of the river do
we know any more about that
continue people are being rescued
animals are being rescued because
obviously as we understand the water
level is a bit decreasing but as we
understand other territories down the
ednipro river uh actually they all the
all the water is rushing there also
according to the Russian Ministry of
Defense we know that on June the 5th a
Ukrainian group blew up a fragment of
the toliati Adesa ammonia pipeline it
took place in the Kharkov region where
some fighting had been reported earlier
some video elements are now circulating
on the internet showing a poisonous
Cloud allegedly moving into the kupiansk
region some civilian victims with the
ammonia poisoning have been reported and
according to the defense Ministry they
received all the necessary medical help
the toliati Adesa ammonia pipeline was a
vitally important part of the grain deal
between Russia Ukraine and the U.N and
the resumption of the pipeline was one
of Russia's conditions for extending the
deal the Russian Ministry the Russian
foreign Ministry rather said that
restoration of the italianati Adesa
ammonia pipeline take some time from one
to three months if there is access to
the facility also the foreign Ministry
blamed Kiev saying that it was the only
party not interested in resuming the
ammonia Pipeline and that by blowing up
the pipeline key of Delta heavy blow to
the efforts of the Yuan and the fight
against hunger in poor countries
okay thank you so much that is uh Julia
chapavalova for us in Moscow